All right, so our goal is going to be to
try to create learning algorithms that
are not quite as smart as you were in
that example, but trying to approximate
that, getting as far along the rock to
Charles continuum as we possibly can.
>> [LAUGH] Okay, we want algorithms
that are Charles complete.
>> No, I think you're probably still
going to beat the algorithms that we're
going to talk about in this class.
Someday, someday.
All right, so the important thing
is that we have to figure out,
what it is that we are trying to learn?
So in this case what we're trying to
learn is a behavior, we're trying to
learn the way of interacting with the
environment that obtains high reward.
And it turns out that there's different
ways to think about this depending on
what kind of behavior
you are looking for.
So one classical kind of behavior
that is very common in the AI
literature is the notion of a plan.
So plan usually refers to
a fixed sequence of actions.
So the kind of thing that says,
okay I see where I am now,
this is the sequence of
things I'm going to do.
I'm going to go left, right, up, up, up,
down, pick up, left, left, down, down,
down, down, down, drop off.
Something like that.
So that plan, once you've chosen
the plan, you can just execute it.
It's just that fixed
sequence of actions.
And this happens sometimes in real life,
there's certain kinds of
behaviors that we just have.
It memorizes a sequence, but
in fact what's the problem with this?
Why can we, in general,
just execute plans in
order to satisfy the kind of goals
that we're trying to satisfy?
>> Well, so, I'll say two things.
One is, I was actually executing a plan
once I figured out what was going on.
>> Mm.
>> Right?
Particularly the-
>> Yeah, that's true.
Right so, part of it is, during
learning, you don't know stuff, so
you don't know kind of plan to execute.
For this slide I'm talking about
behavior structures for after learning.
So during learning also sorts
of weird things have to happen.
You have to try stuff out.
You have to adapt.
But once you've figured
out what you want to do,
you could try to represent it as
a plan but the problem with that.
Okay, so it is true the environment that
I showed you has a property that makes
plans actually okay [LAUGH].
>> Yeah, it's deterministic for
one thing.
So that was the second
thing I was going to say,
which is that the plan worked because
everything did as I expected it to do.
It was deterministic.
>> Good, good.
And so in stochastic environments
you need to be at least a little
bit of aware of your surroundings, you
need to move around with your eyes open.
And so one step in that direction is
something called the conditional plan.
So you can think of a conditional plan
as actually being a kind of program
where plan is a fixed program where it
just executes a sequence of statements.
A conditional plan can
have if statements in it.
You can sort of see what's
happening in your environment.
I'm going to do this,
this, this, and this.
And if I get to this point and such and
such is true, then I'll go this way and
start this action, otherwise I'll
start these things, these actions.
>> Right, so
could one of your if things be,
if everything works out the way
I expected, keep going.
If it ever doesn't, then stop and
try to figure out a new plan?
>> Usually that's not
thought of that way.
A conditional plan would be something
where you have that sequence, and
then there's a branch point,
we ask a question.
And we could, if everything's gone okay,
continue the way we've been going,
but if not, then a conditional
plan has an else statement, right?
>> Mm-hm.
>> It tells you what you should do
in case that that's not true or
in case it's something else that's true.
>> Okay.
>> What
you're talking about is something
more akin to dynamic replanning,
where the idea is exactly what you said.
We're just going to
continue along the plan,
making predictions about
what's suppose to happen next.
If those predictions are violated,
we just generate a new plan.
So there's nothing in the plan that
says, here's what I do in case things
break, instead, we wait for something
to break and then we react to it.
>> Okay, fair enough.
So that's just in time
conditional planning?
>> Just in time planning really.
>> Hm.
>> because again the conditionals
aren't in there.
>> Hm, fair enough,
fair enough, I like that.